my little sister honestly who's much
younger than us
wore a dalmatian costume for years of
her childhood and wouldn't wear anything
else
so it's like there was a girl sister a
voice sister and a dog sister
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who once brought a
build-a-bear from the mall to the lead
singer of this rockabilly band that she
liked elise morales
and with us today we have
such a funny comedian and author they
are the host
of the query podcast on earwolf but
before
all of that they were a graduate from
the bennett academy it's cameron
esposito
yes hello i love that um build-a-bear
fact
yes uh there was a there was a rock a
space-themed rockabilly band from my
area called the phenomenon and
i was in love with them i was obsessed
with them
where did you grow up northern virginia
and like what time perio you're like
definitely
driven me i can see early 2000s
okay so like 2 000 but i would say that
my
peak time of seeing the phenomena was
like 2006
and 2007. yes the reason i ask is
because like
this would have been esca band if it was
when i was in high school like
and i loved i did love scott yeah oh
okay
i listen i had i had ska moments
but um they uh
i don't this there was something about
this
the phenomenons were like different they
were they were in a league apart
yeah i didn't mean to like put them in
it but i just my
my first boyfriend um was in a ska band
a guitar and also wore a rainbow belt
when he performed
and um was
uh like six foot three
um filipino dude who was also the center
of the basketball team
which is like a slightly unusual
demographic
and he uh
yeah he played guitar i cannot remember
the name of his band
but they would open for this band that
was called lucky boys confusion
that was a really good ska band name
right
which actually like then with the
abbreviation was lbc
which was supposed to also refer to long
beach county here
in california but
this is like the suburbs of chicago
voice confusion could not have been like
a bigger because
they would sometimes get played on q101
the alternative station down in the city
and to like go see jason
this boyfriend perform with his band
um and then like you couldn't even
believe it because i was like with the
the openers you know what i mean because
then like lucky voice confusion come on
and you'd be like
i'm with the openers at the all ages
venue that then also had like a foam
party
i was about i was about to ask like
number one what was the venue that you
always
went to what was it called god
i cannot remember because so it was
right next to
or near zero gravity neuro gravity
was the all ages like dance club that
was
i didn't go to high school i went to i
went to high school um
far geographically from my hometown like
my hometown
um had a
public school public high school um
my parents were it was very important to
them that i'd go to a catholic school
and um that was a half an hour away and
so i would take the train there
like a passenger train um not like a
subway
yes and then um anyway
west away from the city further into the
suburbs and then out there
was where like zero gravity was the
full haps and you mentioned literally
just the mention of
foam parties really took me back because
i like i never
went to a foam party but i would always
like
i would be at the mall and it's like
some weird man would be handing out like
pamphlets to go to a foam party
and it always seemed like in my mind as
a high schooler i was like well this is
the most
sexual environment that i could think of
yeah absolutely i mean the other thing
that i will just say about like
sexual environments and specifically
this first boyfriend
by the way he was like the nicest man in
the world um he came to a show
ten years ago it was like the first time
but
um he also was
in like a dance troupe
um that would do like all of the
choreographed
boy band dances so
he went to jock who played football
basketball
but he's also like very skinny he was
also a guitarist
who would wear like a white tank top
with a rainbow belt and then he also
was part of a dance troupe that like you
know you're at the dance there's like a
circle
it's like him and his friend joe that
are like
full like nsync dance that
the picture that you're painting of this
first boyfriend
is like a fully self-actualized person
not limited he was unlimited by
his business was boundless yeah as a
teenager i was so
scared to try anything
well i did a lot of stuff in high school
too but that but
this person this boyfriend really like
does stand out as
somebody who was like really doing their
own thing
in like a pretty cool way yeah
well it's just in high school it was
like so hard to like cross
genres i felt like i i know that like
i felt very like i was an emo
theater kid and that is where i had to
like
be and live and anything that was
outside of that like i wouldn't be
welcomed there and also like i couldn't
possibly
yeah i wonder if
i wonder like i you know we only know
like our impressions of ourselves
but how i think of myself in high school
is sort of as like
one of those people that sort of like
knows everybody and does a lot of
different types of things
and i don't know that that was all like
it wasn't all coming from like a place
of
self-confidence you know like it's not
like it was like
wow she's perfect it was more like
i think that um there was a little bit
of an overachieving thing going on i
also think that
i didn't really necessarily know what i
liked so i just tried a lot of things
um but i really was like fully a jock
and then also like senior year was doing
plays
very funny i was also like on the
student government and i was
pretty like i was kind of a kiss up
but i used the fact that i like knew all
of the deans and teachers
to like get away with a lot of [ __ ]
so that yeah that's what i was gonna ask
you is like
we we've learned about the boyfriend now
let's learn about you
um where would you have like so you're
saying like you kind of
you were a jock living in that world but
also like where socially would you put
yourself in the order of things
so like you know there's like the
popular kids who drink
like that's like sort of a category of
people um
and i wasn't in that group of people
that's like like the
sort of um everybody
at the time it was like a lot of
like highlights it was just like a lot
of there was a lot of
um
sex also
yes so there's like that group of people
right and then like sort of
on like below that group off to the side
are like the people that like my lunch
table you know you like sat at a lunch
table or went to school
my lunch table was like um a mega jock
who had eight siblings
who was my best friend who was like
known in the school like her family name
was known in the school
and then like a person who never did
anything and was not involved and never
stayed after school and
signed up for zero clubs at all who was
just like super
funny and then the like star of all of
the theater department stuff
and then um
someone who was like pretty good at
everything like pretty good at school
pretty good
like the well-rounded person and then i
think i was kind of like
uh the like mega involved
student government one but it was very
it was like this table that wasn't like
we all didn't
share um one thing
it was like what united us was like we
were like the sub
popular kids
um it feels like very like almost like
lord of the rings like you have a member
of every class
yeah and like one representative from
every group sits in the table
yeah like you were appointed by like
okay and the jocks have chosen this
person
etc so like i had that first boyfriend
yeah that was just freshman year
and then um i broke up with him
because i'm a heartless lesbian
i um i started dating
the person who became like my my like
high school boyfriend like
like i did it for the rest of high
school and then i dated him for some of
college
and um he was the captain of the
football team
like he was the best athlete at the
school
he was um like they used to have him run
the 4x100 meter relay the anchor leg and
he wasn't on the track team they would
just be like
would you consider coming by and you
would be like yes and then
please sir he would seriously and then
he would just like so he's like
incredibly gifted and then all of his
friends
were football players so there was this
sort of thing going on where like
because i also think like i'm i was like
a little bit of an oddball
in that like i wanted to be friends with
a lot of different types of people
i like had a wide variety of gender
expressions
like from knee socks to then like
like much later and by the time i was a
senior like
i was wearing platform steel-toed white
doc martin
that's a huge change yes
that's a big difference yeah it was a
big difference in presentation and it
was also like
i think i was friendly with like the
really popular people but then i also
got invited to the like birthday party
of the head of the recycling club
and it was like a pool party and i went
you know like yeah i just
i think i like i think i sort of
because i was queer but couldn't place
that that's what was going on
then also had this boyfriend that sort
of like
repelled all accusations like i don't
nobody
asked me what was going on with me i
think i just sort of was like
in my own category yeah it's it's
interesting because
to be the girlfriend of like
such a like the athlete the school's top
athlete that's usually like
a position reserved for the it girl or
any girl but i was the master of the
football team and i've like talked about
this a lot in my stand-up but it is
actually really true like how could that
be
my life you're right that is the
position filled by the it girl but the
april
isn't wearing steel-toed boots and also
a giant red bird like
so i think what what was happening like
i've been listening
ever since so you were the actual mascot
okay you're the first actual mascot
we've had
oh my god really on the podcast
so you really are breaking i i would say
you're breaking a lot of barriers
because
in the world of like teen culture
the mascot and the it girl are never
there's no overlap there no i know
i mean i know i it truly
i mean and my that boyfriend and i we
were voted like class couple
like our superlative in senior year you
know like in the yearbook
i was also voted next janine garofalo
which is like
anything when you like i've worked with
janine you know so
yeah i've never said this term maybe
someday
you were doing plays as well though
which plays did you do
what was your relationship with the
theater program at your school
so i i
always had like a like overdeveloped
sense of humor and
senior year at my school there are these
one-act plays that are directed by
students right it's like the people that
have been in the theater department the
whole time
get the opportunity to pick their play
and then direct it yeah that's it
um and i
this is my first like like there wasn't
really there wasn't like any comedy like
an impro
like there was none of that stuff going
on so this was the first thing
that i auditioned for like since middle
school when i had been in some place
um my friend michael
who i had run for student council
president and vice president with yeah
we come back to that
yeah i was like put a pin in that one
i'm
directing a play and i went and
auditioned and i got cast as this
i cannot remember what the play is
called but it's it's
about a like caper has happened
something a crime has happened there's a
grandmother character
who is on stage the entire time and you
think that she can't speak
and then like the reveal or do you think
she can't hear or spit you like you
think she's out of it and then the
reveal is like the last line of the
play is her being like i was here the
whole time
whatever it is
one line um but you had to sit on stage
the entire time
i had saved the entire time and was like
in like white
you know like they like spray painted my
hair white and i was wearing like a
thrifted old like
knit skirt set anyway i say all of this
because
um it was super fun and then the drama
department had like uh
awards every year
and i got best newcomer
but i didn't even know to go to the
awards show
and i have never received that trophy
well can you believe that that's
because you know what they could have
gotten you that trophy because they
could get your schedule
they could find you it's not even hard
i know any other trophy if you miss the
award show you still get the trophy
right and it's on the school to let you
know that you're up for an award and
that you need to show up
the awards so that's not on you
though i do imagine as a as like a
theater kid who was like
in it like deep in the theater things
i'm like this this it girl
shows up
one play she's got one line
she wins best newcomer and i've been
slugging it out in the chorus
of all these custom plays 100.
so in what other ways were you like
did you do comedy at all at this time
were you being funny
at in your capacity as student body
president or whatever you were like were
you being funny giving speeches like
what was your relationship to comedy
well i mean i'm always i've always been
a fan
of the in-class presentation like
i literally don't need to even prep i
don't have to read the book
i can it doesn't i don't have any
knowledge of the subject
i'm going to do just fine yeah um yeah
and so like that was always part of it
but um
the well so i actually wasn't
this is the story there was this guy
ashwin
who um had not been
part of the student council bernie
sanders type
coming in with big dreams trying to
shake things up
he's like yeah he's all corrupt like you
know
everybody is um focused on like planning
dances
but they should be this way or whatever
it is okay so he
asked me going into senior year if i
would run
as the president and he would be the
vice president
oh wow and i
did not think that a woman could be
elected president
at my high school oh my god
and so i turned him down and i asked my
friend
michael to run as president and i ran
as his veep i think honestly hoping to
like
be it's a bit of like a kamala harris
situation
yeah michael was you were hoping he
would pass and you would
say
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast of your teenage self podcast is
brought to you by
candid you know i've got a wedding
coming up
i've got a wedding coming up i'd like to
make sure that my smile
is as gorgeous and sparkling as it can
possibly
be for my wedding day and
you know candid
candid is the key candid is the key
candid clear aligners are comfortable
removable and practically invisible
unlike wire braces
so you can transform your smile without
anyone noticing
plus your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement fun fact
my first like real boyfriend in high
school
always said he wanted to be an
orthodontist which is a weird thing for
a kid to want to be it's boring for a
kid to want to be that but
god bless it so hey maybe you get candid
maybe you get linked up with him he was
a nice guy he was a good kid
plus it's all done from the comfort and
convenience
of your own home okay so you get the
orthodontist you start talking to my
ex you're doing this all from the
comfort of your own home
and candid only worth works with
orthodontists never
general dentists like other companies
plus your supervising orthodontist will
be with you
every step of the way
just as my ex was with me every step of
the way
of transferring from a regular english
into honors english which was actually a
really really stressful process for me
at the time and he was really
he was really with me then okay with
candid your treatment includes remote
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan again
just like him on aim checking in saying
how's the situation going do you know if
you're able to switch classes
you never have to wonder how you're
doing you always
know and i love that so the average
candid treatment is just six months
you'll start seeing results
way before then and it costs thousands
less than braces
so start straightening your teeth today
right now
all of our listeners can save 75
on candid starter kit go to candidco.com
teen self and use code teen south that's
candidco.com teen
self code teen south take advantage of
this limited time offer to save
seventy five dollars on your starter kit
candid co dot com slash teen self
code teen self do it straighten your
teeth
and um ashwin ran as president
with um there were these really pop
there were these really amazing twins
where they were identical twins but they
were super different sizes because one
of them played football and one of them
was
in the band
on a ticket with the football twin yeah
okay i thought you were going to say he
ran out of ticket with both of them and
i was going to be like wait so the twins
ran as one unit
like big twin little twin like they're
identical and they weigh
80 pounds different like it would be
impossible to beat
a ticket with big twin and little twins
you can't that's too powerful
yeah yeah it's true yeah um
anyway we lost we lost to ashwin and
the big twin and it was honestly it
still is a
i know this is like i know it's high
school but like i still regret this
this lack of faith in myself like that
really sucks and it completely sucked
that like this person won specifically
also he did a great job
and i when was last time i heard from
him a bunch of years ago but like i
still
heard from him after school and
everything but because i wasn't
president then i just invented my own
job
which was called the president of the
spirit club
which was a committee that i founded
within the student government
that not only like was the mascot but
also
um did like you know grease paint on the
face
oh huge and rented buses and like went
to all the sporting events
wow that is so you
basically invented like a a
like honestly like a shamanic like a
spiritual position for you
like i will take on being like the kind
of the spiritual
leader of school spirit yeah that's
actually that's so funny yeah
exactly like this is what's important to
me you know
and uh and that's what i did instead
so i still i was still part of student
government but i was the
president of roe epsilon delta
which is infrared that
so okay so when you when you were doing
this like
okay walk me through like it's game day
what does teenage cameron have on her
plate on that day
well actually this is why i brought this
specific photograph
okay great so yeah we can start pulling
up some of the photos now too
so i would wear okay so
um i would wear a superman t-shirt
a bandana around my head and then face
paint okay
go to all of the sports games and you
know like you know
you know how people sometimes have like
a giant flag
like it's like it's not a regular sex
flag really really large flag they run
up and down the sidelines yeah and they
wave the flag
so like trump supporters have taken that
tactic now but it used to be a whole it
used to be a fun
thing for everyone i also think it might
be the job of like the male cheerleader
you know what i mean like that yes
that like i didn't want to be a
cheerleader but i sort of wanted to be
like a male cheerleader you know but
that didn't exist at my school
so i made it up um and
to senior year
there was a dance at my school that was
themed
famous couples and many of my
there's one there's like a group photo
everybody here like to my friends
are like dick tracy and
breathless mahoney and one is like the
good witch of the whatever
and the wizard of oz and one is like
tinkerbell
and then person who's flexing whatever
the yeah yeah
the grip allen flexing guy
my boyfriend and i went as each other so
this is you guys as
each other yes so he is wearing
my like game day uniform
and i am wearing his and i wore his
actual football uniform
to the dance oh my god everybody else
was wearing if you go back to the
the group picture even though it was
like a
theme possible costume dance everybody
else was still wearing like a
full floor-length ball game yeah i was
like most of them are
leaning hard to like dance
and this is me i brought an actual
football with me to
dance i like in this photo i'm
like in a full sports kneeling position
and he is sitting on my lap
and like yes being like a girl
you're doing like girl yep were you
like a political teen at all because i
know now
you like you talk about all the issues
on your podcast
you stand up
but at the time were you
like in were you like politically aware
or involved because for me i was very
like [ __ ]
george bush well
i i was but it
is confusing um because
so like i was raised super catholic but
i was also into it like i thought that
catholicism was like
um really rad and specifically there's
like a part of
catholicism it's called liberation
theology
it's super leftist it's like the part
that believes that like
jesus was a socialist that is like
trying to overthrow the power structure
to like
redistribute wealth and opportunity to
the poor yes you know it's the side it's
the part of
so anyway the wing of catholicism
this wing of catholicism also actually
overthrows governments
like in south and central america there
are priests
that like have done that political
action
work i i don't
you know the i didn't at the time see
that like oh this larger institution
is like colonialism and is a corporation
and is you know has all this other [ __ ]
going on i just thought like
faith and religion and specifically this
religion
is like how you make the world a better
place
yeah direct action like not through
prayer but through like actually like
protesting and like [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah
well i i
like i just read people's history of the
united states and they talk about like
how there used to be like radical nuns
who would like
like hold hands in traffic and stuff to
protest like capitalism
i like know those nuns right so like but
here's what's confusing those nuns
it's also still catholicism so like
things that are important to that group
of people is still like
restricting access to abortion making
sure people don't have
premarital sex making sure nobody's gay
you know like
um and so you actually
end up with like this very confused
world view
that's like damn the man i'm a
republican
you know like and that is yes like like
the first time i could vote i voted for
george w bush because i
actually thought that like that these
things
could it's like take the messaging of
the very far left and the messaging of
the very far right
and somehow those things the way that
those things have in common that they
are extreme
that is like what my political
that's where you were at that point go
build
houses for the poor but don't allow for
social programs you know like it's
very confusing so you're involved
in in radical catholicism you're
dating this you're dating this boy
you're involved in all these different
clubs
what was your relationship to your
sexuality at that
time um i was uh
saving myself for
[Music]
marriage marriage which is why i wrote a
book that is called save yourself that
came out
the first week of the pandemic which is
one thing a book could be titled the
first week of the pendant
yeah wow
prescient still a bestseller um but
a shocking thing to have to promote yeah
like literally the my publisher is like
the hashtag is save yourself and i'm
like i don't think
that's yeah i don't think that that's
gonna work
this week right now this particular week
i thought i actually thought that like
nobody masturbated in masturbation was a
sin
i also thought that like sex was
something that
should happen until marriage i also had
sex dreams about like
my friends i mean it was like again
super confusing
yeah did you have like
um a lot of like the queer guests that
i've had on the
pod have talked about sort of like a
celebrity that it's like
i pretended to be a fan of or hate this
celebrity
but it was really there was something
very deeply sexual going on
so the back of my door
in my bedroom growing up was all
like men's heads
[Laughter]
which is for sure like a terrifying
serial killer it was like i would like
cut around their faces you know so some
people might put up like a full
magazine picture but i would cut it on
their faces and then i it was like if
you shut my door it was just like
all of these dudes right um
but on my wall um
were posters of alicia silverstone
who i was obsessed with and i also was
like obsessed with
you know clueless and also like batman
because
partially of her you know and also the
aerosmith videos
well she's a good one too because she's
in all these like
quote-unquote like girl adjacent movies
or like movies that like
uh like straight girl can see and like
and like that's fine you know she's not
like
a super babe like model type where it
would be like okay why do you have
posters
of her that's exactly right i mean also
she's like she's got like a little bit
of a thing going on in terms of like
um some like
confusing sexy energy
i would still think if i met her i would
die
uh clueless was like my number one
we would go i would go to sleepovers at
my friend elizabeth's house and we would
always just watch clueless every time
and it was like we would have a
sleepover every weekend and every
weekend we would just watch clueless and
it was the coolest movie i'd ever seen
and it was so funny and i didn't even
understand what i was watching
and it was my favorite thing did you
do you know the aerosmith videos i'm
talking about or you like tv yeah
i do know the aerosmith videos i mean i
can like i couldn't like make a shot for
shot recreation
right now but i know that she was in
aerosmith that's what's
important that you say that um because
uh crazy
he's crazy not crying the other one so
like crazy is
so you know i was at a catholic high
school where you were in uniform
mm-hmm and um uh actually diablo cody
went to my high school
oh and so if you've ever seen jennifer's
body
the like outfit that
that megan fox is wearing this is in the
poster that's like
our high school uniform wow
and uh anyway so it's like a gray plaid
skirt sort of a thing
and then uh like a button-down shirt by
the way i was always breaking the dress
code
to the degree where they would make me
change into like
shirts that they had in the office and
then hang my shirt
in the office as an example of shirts
you can't wear because i was always like
fluorescent thing um you're only allowed
to wear baby pink
um i was gonna ask what type of dress
code
violation because i was like was it like
all crop tops or
it was such a serious dress code it was
like your collars had to be able to
button down
um and also you like we're only allowed
to wear baby pink
blue or white shirts if you're a boy
you're only allowed to wear
blue or white wipes wear pink so the
boys weren't even allowed to wear the
pink shirt
no but if you were a girl could you wear
the blue yes
okay yes interesting it's just
interesting to figure out what the rules
are and why
yeah men can't be women i mean that's
something yeah and if you wanted to wear
the pink shirt then
something's terribly terribly wrong
um and so then anyway it was like it was
like down to the shoes like what colors
are permitted
and like the type of shoes that they can
be um
for instance white steel toe doc martens
are not
part of the dress code yeah they are
what i wore
um which is why my conduct grade
was almost always nearly failing even
though i was getting like
straight a's they were
just just because of a shade of pink
it's so i was always late i was always
constantly in detention
but then like knew the
you know proctor or whatever like it was
just like
what made you late were you like i'm
gonna go to mcdonald's in the morning
kid or were you just like uh i
cannot get up at 5 00 a.m or whatever
your high school had you do yeah like
you had i had to leave my house at 7 27
to be able to park and go inside
and that tells you what kind of like if
you still at like 20 years later
remember the exact minute i was about to
say
to the minute you have that number
and that means you are like squealing in
and like running
class you don't even have time to stop
at your locker like that's what that
time is
but i also was on the swim team and
sometimes would have to be there um
for 5 a.m practices and so
that those were the only days i was up
around time is because there'd be like
an hour and a half
or something like that where i was just
um supposed to be showering
let's look through the pictures that we
haven't seen
yet um and just see okay
this is a good uniform but just this is
like an example
so wait the this is the uniform or not
my uniform this is like a
not this is a um like a dress down day
like a
day where you don't have to wear your
uniform but you
go with a uniform look anyway
i'm like this is well you know i think
that like
truly the uniform like saved my ass so
much
because like just i didn't understand
how i wanted to present
gender wise and like what a relief to
have there be like
strict rules so you're right like then
it's like
and it was like also you know this was
like a very preppy time
in fashion abercrombie what not um
and i just was like oh thank god yeah i
can wear anything i want but
i know i'm still going to wear a uniform
at least i know what this looks like the
the outfit that the american girl doll
molly
comes with is this exact outfit
that's my favorite that obviously she's
gay just so you know
that's that's the one that's yeah
there's a dog and stuff
she has glasses and a dog so she's so
good
she she really likes history like she's
gay
um yeah i mean i feel like that's so
interesting because
like now i feel like you have a very
iconic style
very like you've got a stylish shirt on
at this moment i feel like you have like
a very
like you have like a look and it's just
so interesting to look back at you then
and i feel like in this picture i can
see you being like
i don't really want to be wearing this
but i also don't even know what i want
to be wearing i mean the other thing is
like i still wear a uniform you know
like if you
were a kid you know because i i had that
also in like elementary school and then
high school and it's like
if that happens for you i think it's
like hard to ever get out of that
because like
you know today or like button mounds and
like khakis and then like before that i
used to wear like
literally the same i had it just if you
open my drawers it was the same pair of
black
jeans and the same navy blue t-shirt and
it was just
two stacks of those things like a
cartoon character
like a cartoon character for like
mark zuckerberg yes
so this photo i feel like is another is
a cute fashion moment
so this is my sister and um
she is three years older than me but
like four school years
um and so she when i got to as a
freshman
she had just graduated and she was like
actually a
member of the pom pom squad and like
um not super involved the way that i was
but she's a dancer and like would go
take classes downtown chicago like ah
dance and all this stuff and she was
very glamorous
and um hot
everything and
then i just came along and i just feel
like i'm like in this but i'm just like
yeah that's like what it was like always
what is that like what is that like to
go into a high school
in the legacy of an older sister who was
hot
i just think that like yeah she had like
a
yeah she had like a hot girl reputation
i think that when i first was meeting
people and they were like
oh you know i think that
i think then people
um just had to understand that like
this was the this was the i mean i
i've said this before it's like there
was like a girl sister a boy sister and
then my little sister honestly
who's much younger than us wore a
dalmatian costume
for years of her childhood and wouldn't
wear anything else so it's like there
was a girl sister a boy sister and a dog
sister
[Laughter]
ideal situation but three girls and um
yeah yeah i mean people just have to be
oh this one's not that one yeah all
right let's look at a couple more of
these pictures before we wrap it
up okay this is me with my best friend
is this the friend you were in love with
and had the
the breakfast with well it's pretty
palpable what's going on here
normal friendship yeah
yeah definitely just two girls who are
friends
i touch myself it's like in
it was in austin powers at the time it
was on that soundtrack
and that was our song with each other
um and our other song with each other
was you're still the one by shania twain
which i requested for her at dances
attending with my boyfriend oh my god
it's just
it is it's a it's a bit of a thing
did you have like any inkling to
yourself like
did you admit at all to yourself like
this is a crush or were you like no this
is my
very normal amount of feelings for my
friend
it was the second one i mean even when i
got to college like
there was a there was a woman i was like
best friends with and obsessed with
freshman year
then there was a woman
that i wrote poetry for
you know at the end of freshman year
like sophomore year there was a woman
who i like
learned to play a certain song on the
guitar and like serenaded her in the
dining hall
and then thank god at the end of
sophomore year i finally met like
another queer woman
and then we like made out but like prior
to that i was just like
yeah and was that something you had to
like negotiate within the world of
boston college where you couldn't be
out like was this a fellow student yeah
it was super
yeah that's very intense we were
closeted for
a bunch of years and then i like had
like a
sort of a fake public boyfriend and
um this is super damaging yeah
i mean i it seems like it would be
really really difficult
d was there any part of you that didn't
want to go like were you
when you were deciding to like go to
colleges or whatever
did you want to go to another religious
institution because that's where you
felt
comfortable was there like part of you
that wanted to be like oh maybe it would
maybe i could
explore if i didn't go into another
catholic space
i was like still a believer at the time
and i was a theology major and faith
peace and justice minor
and lived in peace for a while
yep and um i think that actually
you know the way i was raised was like
with
and then what i internalized from that
um i
i just fully thought it was me like i i
hadn't i didn't know that many people
that weren't raised catholic
or if i did know them because they were
like from my town we didn't talk about
what was different in my household
versus their household so like you know
even when i was at school in love with
this person
and not coming out it wasn't because i
thought like
[ __ ] this place i should be able to come
out it was like i thought
i was devastated i thought that i was
going to hell which is a real place and
i thought
yeah my life was over and i wouldn't
have any friends or a career
so do you feel like maybe some of
the like dipping into all of these
different activities and like trying to
it seems like you like had a very busy
life
of involvement with all these different
things and these like
long-term boyfriends and relationships
was a lot of that just
kind of part of trying to tamp down this
other part of you that you weren't
really
able to engage with at all yeah when the
thing that you want to be
is like thought of as disgusting um
i i think that's like a lot to contend
with
yeah that's why you joined the swim team
and
ultimately it's like five o'clock in the
morning
like maybe i could be something else
yeah oh that that truly breaks my heart
and i
i do feel like we're coming to the end
here so the last question that i like to
always
ask uh everyone and i i feel like this
it fits in nicely with what we were just
talking about but
if you could talk to team cameron
today what would you say
i would first i would show this person
several films
and um ask them to
identify what's going on in their
genitals
touch the part on the doll that you feel
um but i think also just like
like i think that i think i could
always think i'm a little more
cool than i do feel like i
am like talking about that first
boyfriend who is like still actualizing
doing all this different stuff like
you know i also was myself you know like
to
to be like i'm not the cheerleader but
i'm this other guy you know like i
i don't think that i um
i still don't think that i give myself
credit for the way in which i
create space to be who i actually am i
think it's
um i think that's a hard thing to do
because you know
i feel like i think sometimes i feel
like
maybe that's um arrogant
or mm-hmm gross but
um
but i just have always created some
space around me to be who i am and i
think that's pretty amazing
and i hope that someday i get a chance
to just like sit still for a second and
be like
good job kiddo yeah
that's really beautiful i think that's a
perfect place for us to end it
um this was so great it was so awesome
talking to you i really
enjoyed having you on the show and for
everyone listening at home this has been
the roast of your teenage self podcast
you